your interior of your home
is a self-reflection of who you are as a
person
so much of interior design can seem
daunting there's so many choices that
are available
i'm going to teach you how to find your
style how to work with pattern
and how to use lighting so everyone can
look good who comes over to your house
[Music]
go into your closet take a few of the
articles of clothing and drape them
across your living room and see like oh
my god i love that color
so what you look good in you're going to
feel good in
[Music]
at every project this is how i start i
call these vibe trays
it keeps the materials in one place
we have stone tile wood all of these
textures work together
and that's what i love is being
experimental
color is absolutely nothing to be afraid
of living without color
is like living without love it evokes so
many emotions
yellow makes everyone happy there are
many things you can do to make a small
space feel larger
for example having pieces that are up on
legs
or a coffee table that maybe has glass
high gloss paint
can really expand the space because you
have reflectiveness
and dimension and it looks so good
i want to take some of the mystery out
of design
so you feel confident and you can make
incredible decisions and make a
beautiful home
stay curious take risks and beautiful
things will happen
i'm kelly warsler and this is my master
class
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you